Steve Jobs is a man who revolutionized
six different industries this is the
story of his life and how he achieved
that remarkable feat Steven Paul Jobs
was born on a 24th of February 1955 in
San Francisco he was adopted and this
was something he was away a lot from a
young age Jobs learnt to read before he
went to school and often found himself
bored while still a student jobs became
friends with a former student five years
his elder Stephen was niak or was as he
was known they also made a good
partnership when it came to work was had
the engineering skills and jobs had the
vision jobs went to Reed College which
was a liberal arts school in Portland
Oregon he dropped out of college but did
still attend classes that interested him
one such class was a calligraphy course
that job said influenced him to create
the Mac computer with multiple typefaces
and proportionally spaced fonts after 18
months Jobs returned to his parents
house and got a job working for Atari
the videogame company who developed the
famous arcade game pong the simplicity
of Ataris games and lack of need for any
sort of manual influence jobs in his
later endeavors in his spare time was
was building a personal computer Jobs
was impressed and convinced was to start
a company with him to sell the computer
circuit boards Jobs came up with the
name Apple as he was on a fruit-based
diet and had just visited an Apple fall
after a demo a computer shop owner
offered to pay for 50 fully assembled
circuit boards at $500 each more orders
follow and eventually they created the
Apple one personal computer including a
case with a sleek design is set Apple
apart from the other machines around the
Apple one would go on to be sold for the
next 16 years and registers 6 million
sales for the previous 5 years
jobs have been in an on-off relationship
with Chris and Brennan she got pregnant
and gave birth to their daughter Lisa in
1978 jobs did not deal with the
pregnancy well he were ignoring it or
denying he was the father the year after
Lisa was born Jobs took a paternity test
and was forced to start paying child
support his behavior regarding his
daughter is one of the few things he is
remorseful about after the court case
jobs changed he stopped taking drugs
dressed smarter and cut back on his own
interests one of the next projects Apple
took on was a computer jobs called Lisa
once the court case was finished Jobs
took Apple public his valuation went
from five thousand three hundred and
nine dollars in January 1977 to 1.7 nine
billion dollars in December 1980 in the
early 80s jobs have put in charge at a
Macintosh project named after the
previous managers favorite type of Apple
jobs not only created but successfully
marketed a machine that transformed
personal computing one of the greatest
traits that Jobs possessed was his
ability to convince people of nearly
anything his powers of persuasion were
described as a reality distortion field
a combination of his charisma willpower
and eagerness led people to get caught
in this distortion field and allowed
jobs to be able to actually change
reality it made people do the impossible
because they didn't realize it was
impossible
ever since Jobs started Apple he was a
firm believer in great design he knew a
simple logo in sleek casing would set
apart his company and products for an
arrest Apple's first office was in a
building shade of Sony and Jobs used to
study their marketing material and dark
industrial style then he attended a
design conference and was exposed to the
bar house movement which merged arts
with manufacturing creating a bright
simple and clean look this is the look
he implemented on his Apple products
jobs became a master of product launches
from the Mac in 1984 to the iPad in 2010
he combined captivating adverts with
comprehensive media coverage the final
piece of the puzzle was a launch event
with a public unveiling of the product
by Jobs himself after the successful
launch sales for the Mac slowed down in
the second half of 1984 the relationship
between jobs in the Apple CEO also
deteriorated to a point where a him or
me ultimatum was issued at a board
meeting the board sided with the CEO and
Jobs was removed as head of the Mac team
Jobs resigned from his position as
chairman of the company soon after and
he left Apple completely
at 30 years of age he started a new
venture called next next would develop
and manufacture computers for the higher
education market at the same time jobs
that struck a deal with George Lucas to
buy his Lucasfilm computer division jobs
paid Lucas five million dollars with the
promise of a further five million dollar
investment in return jobs owned 70% of
the newly formed company called Pixar
Walt Disney's nephew Roy wanted to
revive Disney's animation department and
Pixar won the contract to computerized
the development in 1988 the first film
they worked on was the Little Mermaid in
October 1989 Jobs gave a lecture at
Stanford Business School and before he
was introduced to the stage was sat next
to a graduate student called marine
Powell the two hit it off straight away
and jobs proposed on New Year's Day in
1990 they got married the following year
and jobs his daughter Lisa now age 14
moved in with them in their new home in
Palo Alto California like at Pixar the
deal was struck between them and Disney
to produce the film Toy Story together
the film was a tremendous box-office
success and a week after opened in the
cinemas Pixar went public since his
departure from Apple the company had
nosedived
there was little innovation and the Mac
had hardly improved and its market share
had fallen to just 4% Apple needed a new
operating system as the latest one they
have produced was not good enough they
agreed to purchase next to be able to
use its operating systems software as
part of the deal Jobs returned to Apple
in a part-time role as advisor to the
chairman when the Apple board decided to
sack the current CEO Jobs took a more
active role getting involved in all
aspects of the business and joined the
board eventually Jobs took on the role
of interim CEO
it was the most grueling time of his
life being CEO of two companies and
having a young family took its toll on
his health Jobs ability to focus helped
Apple succeed again the previous CEO
that approved dozens of different
products and jobs got rid of 70% of them
resulting in over 3,000 staff losing
their jobs
it meant the remaining staff were now
more focused on a smaller range of four
products this strategy resulted in Apple
going from making a loss of 1.0 four
billion dollars in 1997 to a profit of
309 million dollars in 1998 in May 1998
Apple released a desktop computer called
the iMac the teardrop shape design was
unlike anything seen before the iconic
product epitomized Apple's think
different slogan the iMac became the
fastest selling computer in Apple's
history Jobs announced his role as CEO
was permanent in January 2000 jobs liked
to control the entire process Apple but
one aspect he didn't have control of was
the customer experience of buying an
Apple product at a store he began
developing Apple stores in 1999 the
first store opened in May 2001 and in
the first year the stores had taken 1.2
billion dollars in revenue a decade
later
there are over 326 stores worldwide
averaging revenue of 34 million dollars
per store every year but their presence
also helps create a buzz for product
launches and they increase brand
awareness the next thing for Jobs was to
create a strategy to transform the
personal computer into a digital hub
Apple started producing software
focusing on people working with arted
technology
this meant that Apple could control the
full user experience as they now produce
software hardware and digital devices
allowing them to be tightly integrated
something no other company could do at a
time not creating iTunes the next stage
of the strategy was to make a portable
music player the aim was to make the
device as simple to use as possible the
device could hold 1,000 songs and fit in
your pocket the next step was to provide
a way for consumers to purchase new
music through the company jobs created
the iTunes Store and sold songs
individually as well as full albums in
the first six days after launch it sold
1 million songs back in October 2003 a
routine scan of his kidneys revealed
that jobs had a tumor on his pancreas
unfortunately the operation to remove
part of his pancreas revealed the cancer
had spread to his liver
despite the illness he returned to work
and continue to run Apple in 2005 the
digital camera market was being
decimated by the fact that mobile phones
could now take photos jobs realized the
same could happen to the iPod if a phone
could play music the iPod would be
unnecessary they produced the iPhone
which was unveiled in January 2007 jobs
dubbed the devices free products in one
a widescreen iPod with touch controls a
revolutionary mobile phone and a
breakthrough internet communications
device by the end of 2010 90 million
iPhones had been sold the iPad was
announced in January 2010 but the
initial reaction was mixed people had
many complaints ranging from the name to
the lack of a camera or USB port this
soon subsided when the iPad went on sale
in April in under a month they sold 1
million less than half the time it took
the iPhone to reach that target jobs
initially didn't want outside developers
creating apps for the iPhone and iPad
but he later allowed outsiders to create
apps as long as they adhered to Apple
standard and was sold in an Apple App
Store the App Store produced a new
industry instantly 3 years after the App
Store was launched there were 500,000
apps and be downloaded 15 billion times
jobs began suffering another downturn in
health around November 2010 losing his
appetite completely and experiencing an
increase in pain at the start of 2011
doctors discovered signs of new tumors
and jobs took another medical leave of
absence from Apple
with his health deteriorating jobs knew
he wouldn't return as CEO of Apple and
resigned Steve Jobs's personality was
reflected in the products he produced
Apple his intensity and ability to focus
helped create great innovative products
that provided a simple yet seamless
experience for the user
he built a startup from his parent's
garage into the most valuable company in
the world and will be remembered as a
visionary and a genius
if you enjoyed this video and would like
to see more animated summaries of
entrepreneurs and other successful
people feel free to check out the obtain
eudaimonia youtube channel Cheers